- [Voiceover] What is the product
of the smallest prime number
that is greater than 50
and the greatest prime
number that is less than 50?
So let's just think about
the numbers around 50.
So I don't know, I'll start
with five below and five above.
So we go 45, 46, 47, 48, 49, 50,
51, 52, 53, 54, and 55
and I could obviously keep
going in both directions.
Now we want to take the product
of the smallest prime number
that is greater than 50.
So let's start at 50 and
let's go greater than that,
think about which of these are prime.
Now 51 is always a little
tricky one, it feels prime
but it's good to know that
that's 17 times three,
and one way to test a
divisibility by three
is to add these digits.
Five plus one is equal to six,
and we have other Khan Academy videos
on why that actually works.
But six is divisible by three,
so this is not a prime number.
52 is clearly even, so
it's not a prime number.
And so the smallest prime number above 50
is going to be 53.
53. Try things out.
53. Its only factors are one and itself.
So this is the smallest prime number
that is greater than 50,
and what is the greatest prime number
that is less than 50?
So now let's start at 50 and go backwards,
and find the greatest prime number
that is less than 50.
49 is seven times seven,
this is even, and this is six times eight,
47 is a prime number, its only
factors are one and itself.
So really, they want us to
take the product of 53 and 47.
So, 53 times 47,
and we are going to get
seven times three is 21,
seven times five is 35 plus two is 37,
and now we can do four
times, put a zero here
because we're really
multiplying with a 40,
four times three is 12,
four times five is 20 plus one is 21,
and we get, one plus zero is one,
seven plus two is nine,
three plus one is four,
and we have a two, we get 2,491.